bonsoir à tous et à toutes
je suis au drake et je suis le procureur
de vienne
je suis accompagné ce soir de monsieur
le maire nicole williams maire de
villefontaine le colonel jammes qui est
le commandant de la section de
recherches de grenoble et le chef
d'escadron bosserelle à ma droite qui
est le commandant de la compagnie de
bourgoin jallieu
le corps de victorine d'artois âgé tout
juste de 18 ans a été retrouvé ce jour
28 septembre 2020 à proximité de l'étang
de saint bonnet près du stade de la
prairie à villefontaine
son corps a été découvert par les
équipes cynophiles de la gendarmerie
engagé sur place depuis la veille il
était immergé dans un ruisseau et
difficile d'accès il est évidemment trop
tôt pour vous dire à quand remonte son
décès et quelles en sont les causes
un médecin légiste s'est rendu sur place
et a réalisé la levée de corps cet
examen externe n'a pas permis
d'identifier les causes de son décès des
examens complémentaires notamment une
autopsie seront réalisés dans les jours
à venir
un appel à témoins est en cours de
diffusion
toute personne susceptible d'apporter
des éléments dans le cadre de cette
affaire est invité à joindre le numéro
suivant 0 800 200 140 2 je répète 0 800
200 142 mes pensées vont ce soir à sa
famille ses parents ses soeurs et son
frère que j'ai pu rencontrer aujourd'hui
mais aussi à ses amis et tous ceux et je
laissais nombreux qui ont participé aux
battues et au recherche depuis sa
disparition samedi soir
mes pensées vont également aux gendarmes
et aux policiers municipaux qui ont
oeuvré sans relâche
depuis samedi soir pour retrouver
victorine désormais l' enquête se
poursuit sous les qualifications d'
enlèvement séquestration et homicide
volontaire afin de déterminer les
circonstances du décès de victorine
l'enquêté désormais confiée à la section
de recherches de grenoble qui bénéficie
évidemment de l'appui des militaires de
la brigade des recherches de bourgoin
jallieu et ceux de la brigade
territoriale de villefontaine
je vais pour ma part me dessaisir dès ce
soir au profit du pôle criminel de
grenoble seul compétent pour traiter les
affaires criminelles en isère je laisse
désormais le chef d'escadron bosserelle
vous indiquer les moyens engagés par la
gendarmerie
lors des recherches opérationnelles et
je donnerai à paroles ensuite au colonel
jammes qui détaillera par la suite les
moyens engagés dans le cadre des
investigations judiciaires
je vous remercie
en ce qui concerne la ceni recherches
opérationnelles qui ont été mises en
place pour la recherche de dr yo sur
deux journées
la légende américaine mormonne sur le
terrain tout d'abord bien sûr d'un
niveau local au niveau de la compagnie
de gendarmerie départementale de
bourgoin jallieu puis très rapidement
lorsque cette disparition est devenu
vraiment inquiétante
bien sûr des moyens de niveaux
départementaux avec des équipes
cynophiles comme madame le procureur le
rappeler et puis également dans les
premières heures rapidement des moyens
régionaux avec l'appui d'un hélicoptère
de la section aérienne de gendarmerie de
lyon des équipes cynophiles spécialisées
qui venait également de niveau régional
des équipes de plongeurs et techniciens
d'investigation subaquatique qui sont
également venus nous renforcer pendant
ces deux jours de recherches
donc pour les recherches opérationnelles
130 militaires de la gendarmerie ont été
mobilisés
concernant leur instigation 94 de la
section de recherches de grenoble et du
groupement de gendarmerie départementale
de l'isère
appuyé par le service central de
renseignements criminels ont été engagés
sur la direction la section de
recherches de grenoble
depuis hier tout élément susceptible
d'être utile à la manifestation de la
vérité doit être communiquée à l'agent
nombril via le numéro vert qui vous a
été donnée par madame le procureur je le
rappelle
0 800 200 142 0 800 252 je vous remercie
sinon